[Music]
okay
let's go we're playing black mono
ginobili 1848 okay serious players now
all right e5
but
ladies and gentlemen but
and let's hope he goes knight f3
this entire lecture that i read to you
doesn't mean
that you can't have some fun with the
stafford gambit once in a while there
ain't nothing wrong with playing the
stafford and playing whatever guilty
pleasure opening you have
i want to see how the stafford gamut
holds up at an 1800 level let's see if
these guys know the refutation let's
play the staffer knight c6 thank you
stuntman 82 with a prime
all right so this is the stafford gambit
i'm not even introducing it everybody
should know what it is
d3 okay this is getting exciting let's
see if he falls into one of the traps
jumpy gifting to cloud man what should
we do here how should black continue
where should we develop this bishop
the point is that we want to play bishop
to c5 here aiming at the f2 pawn
this creates a very wide range of
possible tricks michiko a v3 with a 10.
so bishop b3 by our opponent
unfortunately he does play a move that i
think takes a little bit of the sting
out
um but it is it's an accurate yep as far
as i remember this is not the best move
uh but it it doesn't you know lose
immediately or anything like that now
the reason it's not the best move is
very obvious uh he's weakening his king
side so after the bishop train look at
how
nasty he's creating all these nasty
little weaknesses on his king side uh
and these are weaknesses which we can
exploit through
targeted play and rapid development so
what should we do here the key word here
is rapid we don't want to let this guy
uh develop his pieces in castle remember
if he plays bishop b2 in castles
that's it the flame of the stafford
initiative is extinguished
knight takes e4 doesn't work and the
stafford you sometimes have tricks
related to that move but knight takes c4
he just takes it queen h4 check he
blocks it with g3 no we want to go
knight g4 and we want to go straight
after this pawn on e3
queen f3
we don't want to let him consolidate how
can we pile up the pressure on this pawn
not 95 guys don't fall into the queen
syndrome don't play 95 just because it
attacks the queen
just to recap
if you're posing a threat you have to
make sure it's actually a meaningful
threat don't make a move just because it
poses a threat
this move does pose a threat but it's a
meaningful one oh it forces this king up
like that and now we have some cool
stuff going on what should we do now
we've got a couple of possibilities here
now as many of you guys are spotting if
the knight were gone from g4 we would
have a pin and so the move knight takes
h2 comes to mind and if i were playing a
classical game
i would play knight takes h2 so what do
you think our opponent's going to
actually wait oh no let's
no bs we're playing knight takes h2 this
is too cool to pass up
i was going to make a point about the
move castles being also very good just
patiently bringing the rook into the
game and then trying to go f5 basically
going straight from checkmate but this
move is too cool to pass up so we're
going to indulge our guilty pleasures
here i actually think castles might have
been even stronger but we'll get to that
after the game and he blunders the queen
i can't believe he just thought and then
did that okay
so very quickly guys
should we take the should we take the
queen
or is there a slightly more accurate
move
should we take the queen or is there a
slightly stafford strikes again is there
a slightly more accurate move yeah let's
just castle castle we don't need the
queen's not going anywhere
by the way what's up tommy castling long
is also good but i'm not playing it only
because tommy suggested i was going to
castle long and tommy suggested it so i
decided to cast a short now
um king f2 now don't forget to take the
queen though this is something i've seen
by the way people being like yeah the
king queen's not going anywhere blah
blah blah
oh my god he actually escaped the pin so
don't forget to take the queen when the
time has come
okay and
here we have a very clear application of
the rule strike while the iron is hot
when you win material your opponent
often follows up with more blunders your
opponent is less attentive to tactical
details in the position what tactical
details do you have to pay attention to
what is this
bushes what is this this is a rook
what can you guys tell me about this
rook this is uh tactical observation 101
it's unprotected
is there anything else that's undefended
there's actually only one
other relevant thing pawn on e5 is a
classic classic right triangle it's a
classic right triangle chat i mean this
is actually
this looks like isosceles
queen e5
the classic isosceles triangle chat
this is a fork and not only do we win b2
but we're going to take all of the all
of the other queen side pawns give me
that
and then give me that and then give me
that and our king is perfectly safe here
the game is over
this is nice now
assuming it goes rook b1 and we want to
win as efficiently as possible
the funny thing is guys which pawn
should we take here now we can take c2
and then take a2 but here's the thing
uh
could a case be made for taking on a2
immediately well the answer is yes
because i'm asking you
who can tell me why it might even be
stronger to
omit taking the pawn on c2
well yeah yeah it creates a password but
i would argue folks that we can take on
c2 and then take on a2 by force so it's
not only the fact that we create a
password because we create a password in
both lines
but there is a specific reason
yeah so
here's this is a little bit subtle
if we play queen take c2
he can walk his king over to g3 you guys
see that
that opens up the defense of the rook to
the knight
moreover that x-ray is the queen so
later on when when we start pushing our
a pawn he might be able to find a way to
get that h2 rook into the defense this
is
largely irrelevant we're totally winning
but do you guys see how this might
actually help him involve another
defender whereas by keeping the pawn
alive
we're creating like a natural plexiglas
uh this is like you know covered
conscious move that pawn on c2 is
sectioning off the rook
uh from from from its defense now should
we defend the spawn yes or no
because and it's amazing like how
instinctual is it to take the spawning
yet i don't think it's gonna ah push it
push it girl
push the phone girl yeah a4 a3
and the game is over
but i hope that makes sense by the way
i hope i hope what i just said made
sense a4
yeah good to see you chica thank you for
the 10 gifted oh my gosh
a3 trying to make him give up his knight
for the pawn
i hope he takes on c7 because we have a
very sexy
winning continuation here
you didn't watch my video on the
stafford guys
um snuffing the stafford
up on my youtube channel from a couple
of months ago or like a year ago
so you guys are welcome to take a look
at it and i just want to give a big
shout out to my man eric rosen
after the game
because
i always crap on him jokingly of course
but
you know for once i'll give him a
genuine compliment i think eric
uh you know when i released that video
um i
you know part of me was like man
i don't want this to come off wrong
i don't want this to to seem like i'm
trying to snuff out you know
what eric is well known for
and i think i made that clear in the
video but eric also went out of his way
to recommend the video and
to be super wholesome about it so i just
uh really really appreciated it and i
wanted to give him a shout out about
that
so anyways um as if anybody needed any
more evidence that he's like the most
wholesome streamer ever okay so what
should we do now what should we do now
okay so queen takes c4 is the fancy move
i was talking about
but we can't take that well it's not a
good idea queen c4 dc4a2 gets a little
bit too fancy
be very careful look at the whole board
can he prevent a1 equals queen he can
play rook h1
and then we will have to basically start
over again because we'll only be up in
exchange so when in doubt don't go for
the fancy move again that's been a theme
today always go for the simplest
continuation if you're not sure
you're not absolutely positive
that the the fancy continuation is
winning
so queen a1 followed by a2 and the game
is over
unless he plays bishop f5 don't pre-move
a2
still to the very very end you have to
be vigilant of your opponent's counter
play and be respectful of
uh your opponent in the sense that
you're not just waving your hands around
and pre-moving everything you're still
applying good practices you're still
asking yourself what the threat is on
every move
okay and of course he's the most toxic
streamer ever
always go for the fancy variation no
matter what exactly
all right no threats you can play a2
and i remind you guys you can always
check the vid i know it's not the same
but you can check the vod for the
um for the latest speed run videos you
might have to do a little bit hunting
but uh i will never make vods uh you
know i'll never put them behind a
paywall so you'll always be able to look
at the last speed run if you missed it
for whatever reason what should we do
here queen d1 check and then anyone
queen yep
all right
well only because i find it a little bit
annoying myself when i want to watch
somebody's vod
honestly um i understand why
what the motivation is behind doing its
subs only
i don't fault anybody for that but to me
um i feel like
you know it's it's more
makes it more accessible if anybody can
watch it
okay
uh thanks for the link jumpy now let's
take a quick look at this i will
completely defer to eric
uh for all of the stafford videos i'm
not going to just rehash
the stafford gambit traps
um eric has several videos that are
expertly made and he talks about all
sorts of traps
now um in my stuffing the stafford video
the
uh line that i recommended if i if i
remember correctly we start with d3 as
my opponent did after bishop c5
um
who can tell me
what move yeah so bishop e2 now bishop
b2
is um
one of the moves but i think that
i've already forgotten what i what i
recommend but yeah you start with bishop
e2
i think that most people play h5 here
and then we play the very simple and
very nasty move c3
um or do we play
trying to remember myself what i
recommended it's been a while since i've
reviewed this because yeah that's it
bishop b2
if they go knight g4 then we simply take
it
queen h4
and now i think that we were supposed to
go something like queen f3 and queen g3
i think that's what i was recommending
and this force is a very desirable queen
trade
so
you know that's something you have to
investigate but just take a look at my
video if you want to know how to play
against it the point of c3
is to prepare the move d4 slicing off
the bishop's contact with f2 that's the
key
um and and that basically ends all of
black's counterplay black has very
little compensation for the pawn so
stafford is a good opening to have as a
backup weapon bishop b3 bishop b3 fe3
and bishop e3 is inaccurate on on this
very account now
here's the thing
why shouldn't you have the staffer as
your exclusive opening even if it works
again i'm going to beat a dead horse
here because this is important
even if the stafford or whatever gambit
line you play brings you amazing results
in the short term
i still think that you should have at
least one opening that's a little bit
more sound so that you can expose
yourself to more positions and build up
a solid foundation that doesn't mean you
shouldn't play the stafford you can do
it for a little rating boost but at some
point people are going to know what to
do
and then you're gonna start regretting
man i wish i had already been playing
some sort of conventional opening
because i've actually encountered
players who play incredibly offbeat
lines
they get up to 17 1800 i think jeremy
sillman talks about this and then all of
a sudden they have to change the
repertoire and they've never played
anything else before so you can see how
much trouble that could lead to
um
so queen f3 queen g5 and now of course a
key mistaking into what should what
should white have played here
the idea was correct to use the king for
the defense but paradoxically king d2 i
think was better
i think the reason he didn't play it is
because he thought it walks into a pin
uh ironically it's this move that walks
into the more dangerous pin this is not
a dangerous pin
and you know we would have probably
gotten the bishop out and then castled
long black i think at this point has
full compensation for the pawn but it's
a very double-edged position maybe the
computer will still prefer white still
the stafford has done its job it's clear
so king e2 knight h2
and i'll be honest the reason i
initially rejected this move
is because of queen f4 and i thought
that what this move does is it forces
the queen trade forces the queen trade
because how else are we going to salvage
this knight and i didn't particularly to
be honest i didn't like this end game
and he's got nice pawns this is probably
about equal but then i spotted something
what does black have in this position if
you're being very vigilant remember the
rook is undefended the king is
vulnerable combine the two you should
start thinking about discovered checks
and stuff
you can play queen h5 check
and if the king goes to d2
black to play
whoa
lack to play can i have three is correct
i'd have three queen f3 queen h1 we're
up in exchange
so if you're playing white you should go
king f2
with the idea of going knight for king
g1
but after queen g6 we've managed to
evacuate the knight even queen c5 might
be stronger forking the pawn in the pawn
uh so this is still amazing for black
that was the key move to spot he
blunders the queen
and the rest is history queen e5
striking while the iron is still hot
looking at undefended pieces and pawns
and then not taking on c2 using this as
cover
uh blocking the h2 rook from
participating in the defense had we
taken here first king g3 if we take on
a2 now
if we play a5 guess what here comes the
rook and it joins in the defense and it
makes it a lot harder to push that pawn
okay the bishop is hanging but you guys
get what i'm saying
you guys get what i'm saying
okay queen a2 a5 a4 a3
now i was hoping that he would take on
c7
here we can i'll think about it as time
and we can play queen takes c4 and a2
because the bishop on f1 intercepts
the rook's attempt to stop the pawn when
in doubt though you don't need to do
that you can just play queen a1 just
like we did in the game
so
i want to make it very clear that
you know i think some people indicated
this in reddit that was a good point
sometimes i can get too caught up in the
fancy
fancy continuation and that could
actually build bad habits if you always
try to go for the flashy line uh you
just blunder more so
i'm going to make it unequivocal that i
always advocate for the simple solution
unless you're totally positive that the
flashy boot works now my idea for the
encore
is a little bit iffy has a kofo has a
focal for the prime
here's my idea i want to play the bomb
cloud
and the reason is that i want to play
the bomb cloud and show you guys how i
would recover from
that situation
what do you think about that idea
because what i've done is i've given
away a piece before and shown you how i
recover from
a position where i'm down material
what i haven't talked about how do you
recover from a position where your king
is in crisis
so again if my opponent for whatever
reason watches this video no disrespect
meant
i don't like doing it but i think it's a
good idea let's go
here we go
g2 bunk cloud time bomb cloud speed on
okay so knight c6 wow you play that
pretty quickly
so
um
why is the bomb cloud bad this is a
funny question to ask it's not actually
bad because the king is on e2 it's bad
because we lose castling rights that's
what makes it so debilitating because
our king is literally stranded in the
center and
what we need to understand here is that
we need to
we need to create kind of a makeshift
wall
for the king so that we can then buy
ourselves some time the ultimate goal is
going to be the castle by hand our goal
in such a position
is to first build
a a very solid central
pawn um you know sort of structure
and then use
that time to buy ourselves some time and
basically drag the king over somehow to
the king side so let's get to work
first first things first we need to
develop a couple of pieces let's go
knight f3
let's develop some pieces and i've seen
icaru do this um i think he's probably
the world's leading expert on the bomb
cloud at this point
d5 that's a great move
essentially you want to play d3
and then get this knight out to d2
holding it very close to your king so in
this position what you don't want to do
you do not want to take on d5 you
certainly don't want to take on d5
because that opens up the center that
plays right into black's hands
so
our only possible move here is to play
let's play d3
uh reinforcing the pawn on e4
i hope this is making sense so far do
you take c4 okay so he opens up the
center but that's okay and if he takes
the queen then we've basically recovered
so i'm a little bit surprised he's done
that so early unless he plays bishop d6
that would make more sense
okay he takes the queen so amazingly he
really doesn't try too hard
uh to challenge the bomb cloud directly
black is still better we have to be
careful we're not out of the woods uh
even though it's an end game that
doesn't mean that you're that our
opponent doesn't have attacking chances
uh so white's position is still pretty
miserable
and
sky you're suggesting bishop b5 but
think very carefully bishop b5 there's
knight takes e4 and that knight is going
to attack f2 so it's a little bit too
early for aggressive play
we need to weigh the possible options
for defending e4 and choose the move
that's the most sturdy and stable thank
you pass me
now a lot of players i think would go
knight c3 here neo1910101 with a five
damn girl but knight c3 is inaccurate in
my opinion could somebody tell me why
why is bishop d3 better than knight c3
there's two reasons for this
two
reasons the first is that knight c3
allows bishop b4 which harasses the
knight and threatens both to ruin
white's pawn structure and to win the
pawn what's the second reason well
there's a related reason it develops the
rook
but also think about which side black is
likely to castle on think about which
side black is likely to castle on
where do you think white black is going
to castle
yes black is going to castle long and
guess what we would like black castles
long if only we could make sure that the
rook on the 8 would not give a check
well that's why we play bishop d3 this
bishop looks bad but when you're
defending as i've said many times bad
bishops defend good pawns
and when you're on the defensive
your you know the glamorousness of a
move how cute a move looks or how nice
it looks should be
you know should be very last on the
priority list it should be not something
you're concerned about
now we need to identify at this point
the potential sources of danger and we
need to find a regrouping asap that's
going to deal with them so what is he
actually threatening
let's take this one step at a time what
is he actually threatening here
he's not threatening to take that's not
a serious
threat it ruins our pawn structure but
but that's okay
how can he exploit this pin in a more
incisive way he can play knight to d4
this is a very very nasty move as you
guys should see because that knight on
f3 is gonna get caught under fire and
that just looks nasty
so
um
the move c3 comes to mind in order to
cover this square with the pawn but c3
has a very obvious drawback to it
what is the drawback of c3 and is that a
deal breaker so
i want the drawback and does that
drawback mean that we shouldn't play c3
who can tell me
c3 he castles long and the bishop on d3
has lost its protection but let's
calculate just one move further guys c3
castle is long
and what the c3 move accomplishes that's
the genius of that move it creates a
little envelope on c2 for the king not
only do we escape the pin and defend the
bishop but we somehow coordinate our
pieces a little bit better and we
permanently stop the knight from coming
into d4s my partner in crime robert hess
always likes to say
pawn two squares between a knight and a
pawn on the same file is very much
detrimental to the knight because the
knight is unable to get to these two
very important squares if that makes
sense
okay
let's see two
which crime
not your face
all right
so i hope i'm making sense so far
we're in somewhat better shape white is
still worse white is still worse we're
not done with the defensive task
no
time to crack the champagne open
but uh we're doing well
all right what now another threat is
attacking f2 one of the hardest things
about defending is just this
constant barrage of threats that you've
got to deal with
and uh you've gotta choose the lesser
evil often you're gonna have a couple of
moves that look very ugly and you've got
to choose the least ugliest of them
yeah so between rook f1 and bishop b3
guys
which of these two moves should we
prefer i think rook f1 is wrong because
it it
see the development is going to be a
little bit too slow my intuition is
telling me that at this point the most
important thing is to get our pieces out
as quickly as possible all right
that's why i like bishop e3 because even
though it allows him to ruin our pawn
structure which probably will
it does facilitate
uh both you know
this rook coming to d1 as well as once
this knight gets out the other rook
uh diving in for the rescue at the very
last second because one thing that he
might do is double rooks on the d5 i go
rogue d7 or d8 and we're going to be
just in time to reinforce this bishop
because moving this bishop would open up
the d file that's what we don't want
bishop h5 that's a great move this guy
is good
this guy's incredibly good so he's going
to g6 potentially in order to target the
pawn so we should use that information
to inform where we put this knight
should we put it to a3
or should we put it on d2
pretty obvious question yeah knight pd2
well t-page he's rerouting the bishop in
order to hit the e4 pawn which he has
deemed a weakness correctly so we go
knight pd2
and uh we're starting to recover here i
think white white is
worse but now the advantage is
relatively small oh but he finds another
way to create a threat and again we need
to be careful
what is he threatening see the mistake a
lot of players would make here is that
you would see eyes threatening e3 let's
go rook a to e1
and you wouldn't notice the second
threat you have to look for all of the
threats not just the first thing that
comes to your mind all of the threats
have to be identified the secondary
threat is knight f2 for king the bishop
and the rook so what we have to do is go
rook h to e1 uh in order to take the
sting largely out of knight f2 the
knight f2 is still a very dangerous move
i don't think he's gonna
okay he is gonna play it now this guy is
he's spicy okay he's attacking the
bishop where should we go
this guy is on fire i have to say
yeah but h3
well bishop b2 is too passive then he
goes bishop g6 and he goes bishop g6
i think we should go bishop e5 we should
at least try
uh to somehow create some threats of our
own maybe buy ourselves a little bit of
time the correct move for black here is
bishop g6 i mean this is some serious
high level chess if he plays it
um but let's see if he if he finds it
bishop g6 would be
an incredibly strong move here because
he would actually have to recognize that
bishop takes c6 and knight takes c5 is
not dangerous he goes f6 okay so he
gives us a little bit of a breather
um he gives us a little bit of a
breather and we need to use this
breather uh to chase his pieces away
asap so what should we do now
get this knight out of there get it out
of there rookie two at all costs get it
out
knight g4 we can get it out further
although we don't have to
and then we start coordinating our
pieces
no these people are good i mean 1800s
as you guys can see at this level they
know what they're doing we got to be
very patient but at the same time i'm
not doing anything
uh that you know the average player
shouldn't be able to find here i'm
making very sensible moves
i'm not reinventing the wheel and now
we're starting to finally i think take
the initiative over from him
see guys the problem with h3 is that
it's too slow he would have played
bishop g6
and the e4 pawn would have been
indefensible so
we have only a very narrow window of
opportunity to get rid of his knight
you got to be sensitive to what the
threats are what the time scale is
okay so i'm very annoyed at this pin
let's get rid of the pin let's go g4
and after bishop g6 we have a very
common follow-up to g okay bishop e8
so what i'm noticing here is that this
creates uh the potential for a discover
check on before
this bishop on b5 has done its job
uh let's make sure it doesn't overstay
its welcome let's make sure it doesn't
overstay it's welcome where should it go
what would be a nice little active
square for the bishop instead of b5 you
can bishop c4 yeah perhaps it can go to
e6 later
um we're going to have to speed up a
little bit
yeah we could have also got bishop a4
doesn't really solve the problem of a
discovered check against the bishop
bishop d3 would have also been possible
yeah yeah bishop d3 would have been okay
although the bishop of course is just
more active on c4 than it is on d3
knight f7 okay so he's getting in that
the knight to d6
we
want to involve all of our pieces right
we've got this opportunity let's get the
rook to d1 uh to contest the d file
okay this should be pretty obvious and
now where should we put the bishop we
could drop it to b3 but more active is
to play bishop e6 jack
but the issue with bishop d6 bishop b6
check is that well actually no let's go
should be six
wow he's outplaying me here
king b8
all right
so we need to somehow we need to retool
our pieces in order to lessen the
pressure just get the valve the pressure
valve down a little bit
um
how do we do that what do we do here
what do we do
how do we
try to
throw some water onto the fire here
see the problem with king b1 is that it
leaves the rook on d1 undefended we
don't want to do that
one option is to make a semi waiting
move when in doubt when you don't know
what to do make a waiting move so make a
move that's going to be inoffensive a
move such as rook e to e1 in order to
secure and connect the rooks now you'll
be able to drop the king back without
fear of this rook being undefended
our ultimate plan here is going to be to
trade as many pieces as possible to
alleviate the pressure on the pawn but
this guy is just
crushing it here bishop g6 if we play
bishop f5 he's gonna play the genius
move bishop f7 and our bishop on f5 is
stranded so we have to go knight h4 and
try to get rid of that bishop even if it
means sacrificing upon this is upon we
are willing to give up under the right
circumstances
[Music]
okay bishop b4 is correct knight takes
c4
okay
it takes
all right guys so
[Music]
what we're going to try to do now and
this is uh this is not looking great i
got outplayed here
is um
yeah knight f5 he goes g6 it's like
we've got a lot of good looking moves
they all fail for these
interesting tactical
reasons i think we're gonna go knight f5
try to activate the knight instead
yeah very accurate andy but
we'll have a look the knight f5 trying
to involve the knight activate it and
slam it into h6 uh in order potentially
to come to f7 the problem is he's got
the very nice move knight g5 here if he
wants he takes first it's a little bit
odd
knight c5
all right so we have a very interesting
move bishop g8
again guys um
no accusations categorically unless like
we look at until we look at the game
i don't want to hear any like
implications i mean obviously this guy
is playing very well it's not a secret
uh but we're we're gonna make sure to
keep it um keep it real until there's
there's evidence i don't think he's
cheating actually i think he's just a
very good player
we're gonna go b4 here to chase the
night away why are we chasing the knight
away because we want to pave the way for
the rook to come to d7
why are we putting the bishop on g8 in
order to lock out the rook we're trying
to lock out the rook
and use that opportunity while the rook
is locked out to activate our own pieces
as quickly as possible
yeah if anyone's cheating it's me
exactly
so i hope this is making sense guys i
know i'm speeding up a little bit and
that's because we've got only a minute
on the clock
yeah exactly um
that bomb cloud really cost us but we've
got a nice position here we've got our
pieces active we're starting to win as
pawns i think things are taking a turn
for the better
this is a very sexy position
all right
f5
i was a little bit worried about that
move
um
okay let's take it
if he goes knight f6 that's what i was
concerned about
right exactly defeats bomb cloud
definitely a cheater
takes that's correct actually
okay so what should we do now guys
and again simplicity prevails don't do
anything
crazy here just
try to win the num the maximum number of
pawns try to win the maximum number of
pawns
now if we go rook g7 trying to go knight
f7 then he plays knight f6
okay he plays knight f6 and we won't be
able to go knight f7 because he takes on
g8 so the simplest is to take on h7 with
the rook rook takes h7
force the rook trade
and after bishop h7 he can no longer
defend that f5 pawn and we should be
winning in this end game because we've
got the outside pass pawn if he pushes
the f pawn he is going to give up the
knight on e4 i hope that makes sense
knight e7 doesn't defend the pawn 97
knight takes up 5. you should see that
97 knight takes f5 or bishop takes f
bishop bishop takes f5 might be even
better
or even even better yeah we could just
push h4
okay so which way should we take the
pawn
doesn't really matter we can take with
the knight okay now i'm gonna have to
speed up guys
um
bishop takes f5 but this is completely
winning he shouldn't have traded because
knights are the worst pieces at covering
outside passport knights are
they're not long range pieces so they
can really only do one thing at a time
and what he's chosen chosen to do is to
try to stop this pawn the problem is the
knight's going to be eventually be
required on the other side of the board
he can't do this forever
um
and and you know we could even you know
we could go king d3 here
and make sure that we defend all of our
pawns
okay now i'm gonna have to speed up so
i'm gonna have to focus here guys sorry
i'm gonna be silent for a little while
i'm gonna pre-move king take c5 and walk
the king over
yeah don't be nervous the situation is
completely under control i just have to
focus
don't be nervous the situation is i
promise you the situation is under
control
yeah so basically king g7 is better
because it keeps the king as far away as
possible from
the night's checks right he's probably
going to go back to g4 and he's going to
get forked
notice how i'm not pre-moving i don't
need to pre-move yet you really you
would start pre-moving i mean when
you're down to 8-7 seconds this is an
eternity this is an absolute eternity um
and we could even play a relatively
leisurely style here
so we want to give a check and we're
identifying the the mating pattern here
go bishop f7
oh god wait i missed that but we've got
this this we win the knight
that's a very important sequence just
take the knight so that you can check
mate easily
yeah this is fine
this is this is uh this is forever
don't even need to pre-move here
it's not sale mates there
oh my gosh i almost stalemated him there
by the way
i was very close to stalemating him
there
we need to
okay i actually forgot he had king a5
and we went
um
nice nice nice so that was the hardest
game we've had so far that was a serious
legitimately difficult game
and i'm very happy that you guys were
along for the ride let's take a quick
look
that's how you recover from a bomb cloud
that was difficult kudos to our opponent
that was a very high quality game i
think let's check the accuracy i'm
pretty sure that
probably was diluted given our end game
play
but a huge kudos to my opponent this guy
is definitely legit and he played an
excellent game for essentially the whole
stretch 97.6 to 91 high quality chest
being played here
okay
um
yeah i was doing my best as well
good stuff good stuff so king e2 bond
cloud
um now
the funny thing is i'm sure the bomb
cloud has been actually analyzed by some
people i don't know what the best line
is for black i would imagine
i think the eval is something on the
order
of minus two so it is losing i mean the
bond cloud is losing and i would say
that the simplest is to play knight f6
and d5 you want to try to open the
center up as quickly as possible i'm not
sure why he played knight c6 that gives
us a a chance to develop the knight and
every developing move here is worth its
weight in gold d5 d3
um and this is where black definitely
made a mistake i mean taking the queen
here it greatly releases the pressure so
i'm shocked
you know given how
amazing his play was
i would just go knight f6 here and the
setup that i would have adopted is the
sort of philidor setup we would have
gone knight b knight b to d2
then try to go c3 creating the sort of
barbed wire fencing not allowing him to
get to d4
particularly if he plays bishop g4 we
want to go c3 to prevent knight d4
and then eventually
you have seen hikaru do this a million
times what you what you're trying to do
you don't always accomplish this but
what you were trying to do is somehow go
like g4
queen c2 we need to defend this pawn
then bishop g2 rookie one and king f1 so
like that's the ideal setup whether or
not we get that done
depends on how astutely black is able to
handle this position although it's
sometimes not that easy to prevent this
plan once we go king f1 we're more or
less fine the king is safe
so
uh that's going to be the the sort of
bottom line idea
king takes d1 knight f6 bishop to e3 so
again we're making moves here not
because they look glamorous but because
uh they defend against the immediate
threats bishop c king c2
bishop c5 bishop b3 no not bribery i'm
doing this to illustrate ways that we
can play the bomb cloud and then recover
um you know trying to showcase various
defensive methods
although bribery is always is always
welcome in this channel always welcome
so bishop b3
um takes takes
bishop h5 is an excellent move and i
just want to compliment my opponent
um for this move
because the bishop comes to g6 now it
was my idea the bishop comes to g6 and
he identifies the biggest weakness in
our position
okay knight bd2
knight g4
um again we identify all of the threats
knight takes e3 knight f2
and we go with this rook to e1 and i
think our opponent played perfectly up
until this moment i think here he played
the move f6 which is just a little bit
too slow
i think bishop g6 would have been much
stronger
and the reason he rejected it i i
imagine is because of b bishop c6 bc 95
but if you calculate just one step
further
what should black take on e4 with this
is a tricky question guys
well we went bishop b5 because our
bishop was attacked
knight takes e4
and the whole point is that if we play
knight takes g6 and say hi gotcha that
knight on e4 has lost its defender nope
rook takes d2 intermediate move
and if knight takes c4 then bishop takes
c4 and the king is really caught in the
crossfire here i mean king b3
f6 is a very strong move
fork nope
um fork of my own bishop d5 fork that
fork over the knight so f6 rookie two we
chase the knight away we create a little
bit of a bind on the king's side we
reroute the bishop to a good square we
make a waiting move just to correct the
positioning of our rooks and ultimately
i think he started going this was good
this was good ultimately i think he
started going wrong when he gave up the
default there was no need for him to
give up the d file
i think knight g5 would have bled to an
excellent position because the knight
covers f7 and attacks the bishop and it
attacks h3 so clearly black is in the
driver's seat here we can still play
bishop d7 looks like a good move you
know if knight h3 we can still fork so
uh you know we can play
but after he gives up the d file and
then allows us to basically imprison
the rook things get really sticky
now we pave the way for the rook to come
to d7 we start taking a bunch of his
pawns and the rest is essentially
history so that was a very difficult
game i could analyze it more thoroughly
but i'm feeling pretty exhausted guys i
hope you'll forgive me
um
you know i think it's it's about time i
called it a morning
uh because i am freaking
exhausted
okay
now you're all good simon
and you i see you copyrighted it too
yeah so uh thank you guys
you know a million for the for the
support
every sub whether it's to my twitch or
to my youtube
it really really helps um the support is
much appreciated
um
you know so
we have a great little community going
here not so little anymore
and i want to thank everybody for
participating contributing to the games
into the discussion and asking good
questions it all
uh plays into
why this place is magical my job is
pretty easy
so thanks to all the mods i'll see you
guys later
thank you everybody for hanging out i
hope you had a good time
thanks for the tremendous support
see you guys later
[Music]